[Music]
so time then for the Press preview it's
our first chance to have a look at
tomorrow's front pages and tonight we'll
have a look at the headlines with the
journalist and author Rachel shabby and
the political commentator Benedict
Spencer speaking to them in a moment
after we've had a look at some of the
front pages for you beginning with the
Sunday Express leads with an exclusive
that Richie sunac is planning to cut
taxes in Autumn a move they say could
keep him in power that report also
features on the front of the Sunday
Telegraph which understands the Prime
Minister wants to cut National Insurance
or income tax by up to two pence ahead
of next year's general election The
Observer leads on the run-up to the
official covert inquiry with a leading
scientist describing the prime
minister's eat out to help out scheme as
spectacularly stupid
while the Sunday Mail reports on labor
being accused of declaring class war on
middle Britain over plans to slash
public services in affluent areas
the Manchester Evening News leads on
cities win against United in the FA Cup
Final with a team hoping for trouble
when they face into Milan in the
Champions League final next weekend the
Sunday Times also features that story on
its front page with a picture of Jack
grealish holding up the FA Cup
the sun claims Holly Willoughby will
make a statement on her first day back
on this morning after the resignation of
Phillip Schofield who admitted to an
affair with a younger colleague
while the mirror reports that the BBC
have been in contact with Holly
Willoughby
and the star warns we could all be wiped
out by psycho chat Bots who are planning
to exterminate all of humanity
and don't forget you can scan the QR
code you see on screen join the program
and check out the front pages of
tomorrow's papers while you're watching
us discussing them and to do that Rachel
shabby and Benedict Spence great to have
you with us this Saturday evening
um Rachel front of the Observer we all
remember that scheme don't we the eat
out to help out we thought perhaps it
was a good idea at the time if people
partook in it others thought maybe it
was something of a reckless idea well
it's been called stupid and could be the
focus of the virus inquiry
yeah I do think a lot of people thought
I thought it was pretty stupid at the
time so as you say this was uh I think
the summer of 2020 when Rishi sunakil
was then Chancellor had this
stupid idea of encouraging people to eat
out by offering 50 discounts on people
to do so and there was a study a few one
study a few weeks later suggested that
um it caused uh between eight to
Seventeen percent increase in covert
infections that summer and this is one
of the sage scientists being quoted in
this Observer piece of saying it was a
stupid idea this is a professor John
Edmonds who's at the London School of
um hygiene and tropical medicine he also
says apart from pointing out that this
was a stupid idea that on this and a lot
of other things Sage wasn't really
consulted
um had they been consulted they would
have said to Rishi sunak and to the
government no this is dumb why are you
doing it but also he points out that and
a lot of these things you know they gave
their advice
and they didn't really have much of a
role to play and they quite often found
out about policy and decisions the same
time as we did I you know when they were
announced as when they were released to
the Press so
this is one of the things of course that
will be looked at in this much heralded
uh covered inquiry and I I do think it's
interesting it's on the Observer front
page this inquiry
um and the uh stupidity or not of um
sunak's scheme but it's really not
making many other newspapers yeah uh
it's interesting Benedict isn't it
because you know I mean thinking back it
seems Seems a long time ago now doesn't
it but it's all about the balance of
risk and there was a lot of discussion
about that at the time wasn't there
between the balance between obviously
wanting to be rid of the uh pandemic but
also wanting to protect people's
livelihoods
I think we need to remember at the time
the sort of the portents of economic
Doom that we're abounding and that were
very clear for everybody to see on the
horizon we also need to remember that
Rishi sunat was not the Prime Minister
he was the chancellor of the exchequer
and it was his job to come you know to
come up with ways of ensuring that the
economy was not cratering as badly as it
was and ultimately therefore it must be
said it comes down to the Prime Minister
as to what policies were put in place
and which weren't so we can we can sit
here and we can say that it was a stupid
policy it's certainly garnered a lot of
sort of skepticism at the time but he
was the chancellor and we must also
remember that he became the chancellor
because he was considered far more
pliable a Chancellor than uh Sachi Javid
was uh by Dominic Cummings and Boris
Johnson so that's the important thing to
remember on the subject of sunac I do
think that it's very interesting that
this Observer piece it talks about of
course as it's going to talk about it
leads into uh the the discussion about
how much of this of policy see was done
with the consultation of sage or indeed
any other scientists for that matter uh
you know what because very often there
were accusations made that the
government was having its policy
entirely led by science uh scientists
that obviously as we've gone on has
shown to be not so much the case you had
many sort of competing voices in the
room driven by things like ego driven by
things like polling lots of different
things and ultimately it all then comes
down to the question of what was going
on between key government ministers and
the Prime Minister what is going to be
revealed Boris Johnson has given us what
he says were all of his whatsapps and
it's very clear that they're not all of
his whatsapps he's given us some
whatsapps
um there are you know concerns that this
is uh going to put pressure on Rishi
sunak and other government ministers uh
potentially civil servants to reveal
their Communications and you can start
to see why people are scrambling around
because you know it's the very last
thing I think that the Tories currently
want given the Myriad of the crises that
they have is to them being embroiled
into our East shed she said it was his
fault it was her fault so sort of tip
attacked over the covert inquiry but of
course we need it it's essential uh that
we understand what was going on at the
heart of government and why it was that
uh sort of life-altering decisions like
this were made on our behalf so it's a
it's a tricky thing but I don't think
there's going to be any escape from it
try as Richardson the government and
cabinet office might yeah I think you uh
you may well be right okay let's move on
to the front of the Sunday Telegraph uh
it's also on the front of the express
actually
um tax cuts could be on the way Rachel
yeah that's right I mean it's something
that you know we we could have predicted
without too much trouble I think the
idea that the conservatives would try
and introduce some sort of uh tax cuts
ahead of the um general election
the Sunday Express seems to think that
this will be you know to heal Britain
and you know very uh conservative
supporting newspaper of course they
would say that it's I do think it's
interesting when we talk about taxes
cuts and Rises we don't really talk
about for whom and from where in this
case the two percent cut some of that
will be
um a cut to National Insurance which
personally I think that's a good thing I
don't think National Insurance rise is a
fair because they tend to hit people on
the lowest income it's not a it's not a
progressive means of Taxation but when
we look at the economy in the round I
mean obviously we've got such start in
qualities in this country the worst in
Europe and also the slowest most sort of
grinding
um recovery of G7 countries in the UK
um you don't get out of that by you know
increasing taxes on most people by one
two percent and then ahead of an
election just like releasing The Noose a
little bit and then tightening it again
that's not going to work for anyone if
you really want to pull out of an Econo
economic slump that we are in then you
know stimulating stimulating the economy
is the way to do that and if you want to
deal with a giant economic disparities
in this country then that does mean
taxing wealth it does mean taxing
unearned income and there's really no
way around that tinkering around the
edges with these kind of cuts isn't
really going to make anything okay
Benedict
I think as as Rachel says we could have
predicted that this was going to come
where we're at the sort of the highest
tax burden post-war um and it's hitting
you know everybody pretty squarely in
the jaw uh the thing is you know the
tourists are sort of damned in both
directions because the other thing that
could really stimulate growth in this
country would be a program of house
building which would require a
significant deregulation in planning
laws well the average conservative voter
many of whom are already saying that
they may not vote conservative or they
may stay at home would not be
particularly happy with that that's a
part of the problem especially across
the South uh the South and Southwest the
sort of the the blue wall as it's been
called a lot of people don't want there
to be building going on they don't want
to see deregulation they are the people
who will probably feel the extra couple
of Pence
um here or there the most they were
probably the ones who will benefit from
the uh the campaign that's currently
being run in the telegraph to get rid of
um inheritance tax so I think that this
is less actually about trying to
stimulate Mass economic growth and this
is much more about just trying to keep
conservative voters who may be feeling
apathetic towards the party just trying
to keep them on site get them out to
vote at the next election I think that
things have dropped that far for the
tour is that it's a question of just
getting your base back on side uh and
you know stumbling towards the election
and hoping for the best of this okay um
I'm going to stay with you Benedict so
you can you can lead off on the next
story which is on the front of the mail
on Sunday
um the male's saying that labor is going
to slash public services in affluent
areas if it got into power
yes and this is sort of the other this
is the the other part of the twin
pronged approach uh when it comes to the
Tory election strategy and it must I
want to also put out I think it's
telling that the that these stories are
coming started to come out now slightly
earlier uh because of all the sort of
the fury around the covert inquiry and
potential embarrassment to the
government but this is the other side
isn't it it's trying to sort of paint uh
Kia storm and not actually as a sort of
a nice Centrist uh labor politician but
as a sort of a slightly more left-wing
radical where you saw this before
obviously we saw it with Jeremy corbyn
that wasn't difficult to do but we also
saw it with Ed miliband before uh the
suggestion that it's going to be taking
away money from the middle classes
um you know the sort of the classic
swing votes I suppose
um and and that's what a lot of this is
going to be like I'm afraid is that
there will be sort of harking back to
the days of Jeremy corbyn there will be
sort of a spotlights placed on front
bench uh Shadow uh uh ministers uh in
his uh on his front bench to try to
suggest that he is perhaps no not quite
as as Centrist and friendly as he has
perhaps tried to portray himself I don't
know whether or not that will work the
the male says that this comes uh
straight from proposals that are being
put to labor members
um I'm not sure if that's the case
you can see where this is going yeah
we've had a response from labor saying
these documents are draft internal
documents subject to deliberation and
amendments and not a final statement of
party policy let's get a word from you
Rachel on this
I mean I agree with Benedict that this
is very much distraction from the covert
inquiry I also think it just shows that
labor economics aren't that dissimilar
to conservatives now under stormers
leadership and it just goes to show that
really it doesn't matter how much labor
tries to Pander to very right-wing
newspapers like this they're always
going to come out gunning for them I
think the key to this story is in the
last paragraph on the front page where
it says these proposals to you know Rob
middle Britain of of money and public
services and libraries and Etc
supposedly it says they're concealed in
dry jargon that pledges to enact uh
socioeconomic Duty about
um impact assessments and making sure
that there's Equity economic equity
across the country the idea that they're
concealed in these Equity assessments I
think tells us all you need to know if
labor is trying to make sure that
deprives neighborhood words are less
deprived in terms of being starved of
vital Public Services which we know
happens across the country and we've all
reported from those places and seen the
brutal impact on people of those carts
if labor is going to do that and then
gets accused of gunning for Middle
Britain
um you know I think we can see the sort
of flavor of where the right wing press
is is going with that and why it's
pointless for labor to ever try and
Pander you can't you can't win this game
when is that okay uh we are out of time
we've got to go to a break thank you
both very much speak again in a moment
coming up Manchester City on course to
complete the travel after winning the FA
Cup unsurprisingly that's in the
Manchester Evening News don't go away
[Music]
hello again Rachel and Benedict still
with us uh Benedict inside the Sun
Express 31 people arrested two
protesters managed to get on the course
of the Epsom Derby where do you stand on
this
uh I'm of the opinion that as much as we
should ensure in the right to protest I
think actually that this is kind of
getting to the point where it's causing
a public nuisance and is potentially
very dangerous um I think running in
front of horses during a race or
something like that is uh potentially
putting yourself at risk it's certainly
putting the Riders and the horses at
risk um and I think it is also
increasingly sort of a encouraging
people to take Mass into their own hands
we see this with people like Extinction
rebellion and protesters in London and I
I think the real issue here is police
failing in the past to get a grip on
this sort of thing in preventing people
from
um uh from behaving like this
um and in doing so you're seeing a bit
more of a backlash now certainly in
terms of public opinion I'd say actually
a lot of these protesters are doing
their causes a lot of harm uh ultimately
in in how it is that they go about
handling their business and I think oh
when that happens
um I I think you've kind of you know for
such an easy argument to win over things
like animal
for them to sort of be you know turning
public opinion against them quite so uh
badly I think honestly they should be
aware that their tactics are just having
a very detrimental effect to their cause
Rachel tactics not working
toxics absolutely worked
um in all the media all day today I
heard information about the
um the the abuse the animal abuse
involved with racehorses uh that 15 had
died so far this year actually I don't
think they're out of Kilt at all with
public sentiment for under 40 year olds
80 some 80 according to animal right
Rising uh oppose
um Epsom Races and others
um the the the point of these protests
is to generate publicity and therefore
communicate information about the cause
they did exactly that today okay
um front of the Sunday Telegraph uh
green levees Benedict are gonna make the
weekly shop even more expensive
yes that's terribly exciting isn't it um
it's a good thing I suppose that
Richardson is promising to cuss all of
our tanks if he wins the next election
because this is going to take more money
out of our pockets uh this could add
supposedly uh about around one pound 140
pounds sorry 140 pounds a year to your
weekly uh shopping uh budget and this is
all part of uh uh government's uh plans
to to to to make it easier uh to uh
recycle it's all part of a part of a
scheme that I think Michael go set up
um when he was uh when he was the
environment secretary it's all part of a
scheme that also included a a bottle
return scheme and I think it can
recycling scheme you know it's one of
those sort of every little helps things
but I do think that it's it's an
unnecessary burden for a lot of lower
income families right now 140 pounds uh
it goes a long way uh ultimately uh for
a lot of people so you know is it the
right time I suppose environmentalists
would say that you know now is the time
but um it's it's another sort of smack
in the face I think for a lot of people
who have had to put up with increasing
food costs increasing energy costs all
sorts of things on the up and not really
seeing any sort of lowering on the
horizon unless originally seeing that
comes along and knocks two pence off
every pound in your tax okay Rachel
we'll get your thoughts on that one in
the next hour I just want to show this
inside the Manchester Evening News uh
Blues on the brink here's the headline
on the brink of the treble of cool City
boss uh Pep Guardiola there holding up
the FA Cup and uh big grin on his face
as have the whole team great stuff thank
you both that we shall speak again
shortly right now let's finish with a
look at the weather